SPEAKER 1: BigQuery is
Google's fully managed,
petabyte-scale, low cost
analytics data warehouse.
Let's see how to use
BigQuery with C#.
First, make sure the API
is enabled in your project.
A service account exists
to make API calls,
and proper access control
is set up for BigQuery.
All are explained in the
codelab in the video notes.
In class shell, let's create a
simple .net console app and add
BigQuery API NuGet
package to the project.
Open the online code editor
and navigate to program.cs.
We will query a sample
table called Shakespeare.
It contains the number of
times each word appears
in each work of Shakespeare.
Let's count the total
number of each word.
Reference to BigQuery library,
create a BigQuery client,
and get the table that
we are interested in.
Construct the SQL to count the
words, and execute the query.
Finally, print the results.
Let's run the app.
There you go.
You just used BigQuery with C#.